it is kind of corny to think about
Arnold Schwarzenegger on a robot series
you know and me already played around he
did it already yeah people would be
sitting there the whole time going to
man and black as a robot I know he is
and guess what robot he is don't Omo
Naruto yeah then we're gonna get for
this one the robot from lost in space -
uh that was decommissioned after being
up the series froths probably the
smithsonian's for the first popular
robots you know about lost in space to a
robot just TV history never I watch a
lot of TV do you is that where you learn
about your hip-hop a wolf hip-hop
culture of hip-hop so you did you watch
West world I did yeah it's for an island
you thought it was good you know the
robots are taking over well I don't know
if they are not even seen the finale
know them to say that's what's gonna
happen
that's the vibe you're getting the old
hip-hop culture was just some alec
rebellion almost coil are but
communities nobody's talking about
hip-hop culture people really hate Craig
she's the [ __ ] worst
he is the [ __ ] worst